[Applause]
by the way
amazon here we come
watch
watch
[Applause]
big labor supporters like president joe
biden are cheering the first successful
vote to unionize workers at an amazon
facility in this case an 8 000 worker
warehouse in staten island new york
spearheaded by a couple of best friends
who built support on tick tock the new
york times gleefully called it one of
the most significant labor victories in
a generation and indicative of an era of
rising worker power former times labor
reporter stephen greenhouse called it by
far the biggest beating the odds david
versus goliath unionization win i've
seen
in 25 years of reporting but the staten
island story is overshadowed by other
colossal unionization failures including
attempts to organize other amazon
warehouses such as in bessemer alabama
where last year 71 percent voted against
joining the retail wholesale and
department store union which lost about
a quarter of its members from 2002 to
2019. it's proven so hard for unions to
gain a toehold at amazon because it's
actually a pretty good place to work if
we are indeed in a time of rising worker
power that's because of incredibly low
unemployment rates and historically high
job vacancies giving the rank and file
more leverage than ever to negotiate
more pay and better conditions for its
part amazon has consistently increased
its wages and benefits to attract and
retain workers especially during the
pandemic when it went on a hiring spread
it set a minimum wage of 15 an hour back
in 2018 and last year boosted its
starting wage to 18 an hour while also
offering health insurance reimbursement
for college courses and signing bonuses
of up to three thousand dollars more
than anything else those sorts of perks
explain the overwhelming failure of
unionization efforts for the second year
in a row linkedin named amazon the top
company to work at if you want to grow
your career it's not just amazon either
the main reason that unions in the
private sector have been fading for
decades isn't because there are
union-busting pinkertons terrorizing
organizers but because of the changing
nature of work and the willingness of
employers to offer better terms unions
flourished during the year of assembly
lines and standardization when schedules
were rigid and outputs employees and
even customers were expected to be
identical as everything in our lives
becomes more personalized it only makes
sense unions would fade in 2021 just six
percent of private sector workers were
unionized down from 17 in 1983. unions
are even losing cloud in the public
sector after peaking at 39 in 1994
unionization among federal state and
local employees is down to 34 and shows
little sign of turning around if k-12
teachers are any indication the decline
is explained by union's inability to
increase starting salaries while unions
such as the nea and aft successfully
lobby for health insurance and
retirement benefits the
inflation-adjusted average starting
salaries for teachers have actually
declined from a decade ago why keep
paying dues to a union that isn't
delivering to younger teachers who are
more interested in money now rather than
promises down the road labor organizers
are turning to the federal government
for help in strong arming workers to
rejoin their ranks the protecting the
right to organize act or pro act would
abolish right-to-work laws that keep
unions from forcing non-members to pay
dues in 27 states but the pro act which
would reclassify millions of independent
contractors as employees has no chance
of passing an evenly divided senate
especially in a midterm election year
where the democrats are already expected
to lose big in both houses joe biden can
come after amazon starbucks and any
other public or private sector employer
all he wants but it's unlikely that he
or any other politician or labor
organizer is going to be able to turn
around a decades-long decline in union
membership
the biggest problem for unions it turns
out is that workers are making real
progress without them